I want to skip over the whole acting
part because I think we come back to
that later I want to cut back to it if
you want to talk about that depression
to happening but um flash-forward
depressions I reached some success in
terms of acting every some success in
terms of like social media or people
would say you know what I mean yeah then
I still had depression and I was like
you know this is weird like I thought
that this was supposed to go away when
when things are good I thought that's
what how depression works and then I
looked up and I was like oh that's how
depression works it doesn't go when
things are good but then I started
thinking where I'm like do I want
depression yeah so I started to be new
things I start I took school I did all
that stuff and during my process of
doing school I also decided to do
stand-up comedy like an idiot the
stand-up comedy is very terrifying and
it's very very hard and I wanted to
conquer that within myself and so I took
up stand-up comedy in the stupidest way
I didn't even start small someone hit me
up and was like hey do you want to do
stand-up comedy for beginners and I was
like yeah and so he put me down on the
schedule and I couldn't back out I was
like oh very harsh oh my god myself into
so I did it so then I'm I was doing it
and then I was going to church during
the time and then I'm I was having a
moment with God I was in worship in the
singing praise and all that stuff and I
came home and I was bummed because I was
working on stand-up comedy and I
couldn't find the right thing and I was
talking to my friend who does stand-up
comedy you know like what do you know
the most and I was like I know
depression like because I kind of
thought I did I don't know a depression
I don't know anything about depression I
know my version of depression you know
yeah which is hilarious but people think
they know depression just cuz they know
their own version you know but anyway
this is like way coming back to it I was
um
I was in the mirror trying to run my my
jokes because that's what I do when I
prep my jokes is like I do it in the
mirror to see if I can actually like do
it with confidence to see if I even do
it can do it right what do I look like
doing it I started running my jokes and
then I stopped for a moment and then I
just started praying I was like I I'm
not doing it right I'm not doing it
right and people aren't gonna laugh
because they know this is this isn't
this isn't feeling right you know what I
mean yeah and they're gonna see that it
doesn't feel right people people can
read your energy especially if you're on
stage you're the lights smashed on you
and they're all looking at you they can
they can tell when you're not feeling
good you know
and I mean I'm sure you know you do not
stand up like God dude yeah it's very
very terrible always still terrified
anyway so I was there and then I started
praying oh my god
how can I get good at this and then a
little voice again came up and he's like
talk about something something real not
just something real about something real
and I was like I looked in the mirror I
opened my eyes and I was like all right
I'm gonna talk about depression and then
right when I was about to write the
jokes about depression another voice
came up and is like is this really what
you want to do you want to talk about
depression you want to be the guy that's
depressed do you want to have depression
and I looked at myself in the mirror I
was like do I have a choice and then the
voice was like you have a choice now
this is the words give me a controversal
because people say there's no choice in
depression and I wholeheartedly agree
when you're in depression you can't do
nothing you know and I know hardly agree
and I don't know why this was a
situation for me it's an anomaly for
myself as well and I feel very blessed
that I got this this opportunity to feel
this way so don't get me wrong don't
don't think that that's the norm that if
you look in the mirror and think I don't
want to be depressed you won't be
depressed that's not out anyways for me
this is how it was I was like do I have
a choice and a little voice in my head
said yes and I said serious yeah I was
like yes and I was like I don't want to
be depressed and then suddenly I felt
like God was like I you're not gonna be
depressed you're not gonna have anxiety
anymore but you're gonna deal you're
gonna deal with your problems you're
gonna deal with everything that you have
kept hidden and I was like what do you
mean I don't keep nothing hidden my
life's on the on the internet I tweet
literally how I feel I post literally
what I feel I even have a purse of like
flowers I'm like I am real God and then
um it just kind of hit me even harder
and I was like oh my gosh I'm not real
with myself like I I have been seeing
myself as Who I have defined myself to
be who people have defined myself to be
as opposed to who I am to who God made
me to be I know that sounds weird but -
how let's let's say in the New Age
way because I feel like people get that
better - who the universe made me to be
you know but like um so I started at
that point I just started to just be
real with myself and I was like okay Who
am I I keep you know like people keep
saying I'm a good-looking dude but I
people see this I see all of my 28 years
of life and majority of my life I was
not good-looking but that's not who I am
anymore now like people do say I'm
good-looking so I should trust them I
should feel that way you know and I was
like okay all that feels nice
oh thank you these people actually think
that way about me that's cool and so I
started being real with myself and I was
like oh okay that's where I fall short
so this and this and then it got to a
point of like me doing the stand-up
thing and then I was real doing the
stand-up and it actually worked
you know I people laughed at my jokes I
started exploring more and then I
decided to get baptized and during the
baptism it was it was fantastic I felt
like a new person and um it just really
helped me um repurpose myself the moment
that like it said I didn't have to be
that way I started to look at myself and
I was like alright well I'm feeling this
way for a reason you know what is that
reason why don't I feel fulfilled and
then I realized that like I pointed my
life at what the world wanted me to
point out and and it's not the fall of
the world I feel like society nowadays
the culture of being very I guess
material is just it's just innate
because that's the culture we live in
and I don't want to blame anybody you
know yeah but that got into me so hard
that I didn't even realize that that's
what I was pointing at and I couldn't I
couldn't be happy because I needed
things I needed I needed success I
needed money I needed to have a car all
these things that people tell you on
like television all these things that
people tell you got to have these things
and to a certain extent you do have to
have money because you live in a world
that is money based you need to provide
for yourself you can't be an idiot you
know but then I didn't need that to
survive because I have enough money I'm
not like balling and money Power Rangers
didn't pay us that much like I have
enough money to survive from my family
and to be okay now and so I was like I'm
very thankful for that and then I
started to reorganize my needs and at
that point psychologically what started
happening when I when I got baptized is
I start to reprioritize myself as
opposed to being like I wanna I need
success for me that was like worshiping
the idol of success in like money and
wealth and fame and fortune like this
that's the that's but also it's kind of
like it sucks cuz that's how we live you
know that's the world we live in but um
I realized I didn't need that and I was
like I don't need that so what do I need
I need food I need good people around me
I need water I need air and like a place
to live you know stuff like that and
maybe enough money to live for the
future yeah that's the meta money I had
and I was like do I have enough for that
am i cool I'm gonna partition that I
started to partition that so during that
time like I started to change my life
drastically I started to like look at my
finances I started looking at banking
and then I started to get that in order
and when I got that in order I I felt a
little bit better about myself and I
felt less pressure and then I started to
feel less anxious about things then on
top of that I was like alright I'm not
booking why am I not booking well I
could go the standard route and say oh
yeah it's because we are Asian there's
not enough jobs and I'm not you know the
industry's against me I don't know
enough people I'm not enough of a social
person I'm not booking I could go down
that route and I was like but I don't
want to go down that route so what right
am I gonna go down alright cool so I'm
gonna go down the route of like I'm not
good enough I'm not booking because I'm
not good enough so I put that on myself
but it was it was a positive thing then
I realized because I was like oh shoot
the moment I realized that it's my fault
that I wasn't booking I started getting
doing better and then I booked I booked
the show that was fantastic for myself
but like that that happened only because
I realized I was like I wasn't doing
good enough and I'm not good enough and
if I'm I get good enough then they won't
have a reason you know it's like yeah
they can they can give me the
limitations of like obviously like yeah
you're Asian you're not gonna have
enough roles for you
I don't know what else but now it's also
different like the industry is really
geared towards Asian was just fantastic
and I'm so thankful for that but like I
could take that route because that is a
fill for your for your depression
depression it's more for you you kind of
got a hold of it by taking control of
the things that you could control I
started listening to you
yes yes so what you're saying yes but I
did it by listening to it in a in a
realistic way yeah as opposed to
listening to it in a way that lets it
control me I started listening to it in
a way that's like alright dude you're
gonna be in my head
you're gonna dog on me I'm a dog back on
you you're telling me that I'm not good
enough fine
imma be good enough you tell me that I'm
not good enough with my finances fine
I'm gonna take classes now look now what
what are you gonna say now
well you're not good enough in this area
fine imma do it I'd do it and then he
can't say nothing anymore yeah so now
he's quiet it's it's it's like a it's a
concept that he meant I mean I think
it's easier for you to say them for me
cuz i i i mean people people say i have
been depressed but i don't know if i've
ever have because i didn't never
categorize it as that i'd yeah i just
call this a powerful thing to ya know so
like i've just you know that's that I
guess that was like the one of the
bigger issues that I had with a lot of
people they go know you've been
depressed you have to fall in and out
like I'm not you don't know because like
well that's how I explain it to them was
well let me just say that if you're
saying that people deal with the
depression in different ways then maybe
I'm dealing with mine by saying it's not
depression but that's when you beat when
people can react to the listeners
listening if you have diagnosed yourself
a depression or if somebody is diagnosed
with depression listen to what David
saying because you have that power to
declare it within yourself and I laughed
because I did that and it's dangerous
and I mean that seriously now because if
you categorize yourself as a depression
you may have three categories that fall
into depression but the moment that you
categorize yourself as depression you
start thinking in your own mind that you
have everything that it says you don't
have everything that it says you have
parts of what it says because depression
comes in different spectrums and factors
you know no but in the moment that you
take it on as a depression then it
becomes the loop of I can't get out of
this [ __ ] without drugs because I'm
depressed
yeah that's unhealthy yeah I just get
scared sometimes because you know I
don't have kids yet but I just don't
want everybody to always think that a
pill will fix something or that or these
problems are so I'm not anti medication
oh you're sure I don't think anybody is
like I they're they're very scientific
and conclusive studies that you know
some people do need medication I yeah
and if you have to kill yourself dude
okay if you're about to kill yourself
take the medication
take the medication so somebody can help
you no you know what I mean I think like
for me like I just it's weird because
the the response that sometimes I get
and like I said it's not subject like
tough on a lot because I feel like I
haven't been through it so I don't
really feel like I'm an authority on it
yeah but I don't think anybody that yes
if you're like a psychologist yeah like
oh like the same reason why people get
angry at maybe somebody like me who says
well I I don't know what it feels like
or if I say there's like different
levels to it are the same reasons why
they it's like their argument it's the
same thing it's the reason why they're
angry at me I'm like I'm telling you
like I feel like there are levels to it
but you can't sit there and keep telling
me that I should be depressed that I and
what I'm going through anybody's telling
you should be depressed like well you
tell them right back to their face that
no yeah I don't know what what you want
me to say that'll make you feel better
do you want me to say that what I was
going through is depression would that
make you feel better but it doesn't make
me further so I can't do that that's why
I think it's like an in it's not a you
wanna it's a little like I get a jail
free card for feeling that
responsibility because but this is not
set for everyone for me that's how it
was for me yeah like from me saying
depression was a get-out-of-jail-free
card because it's like I'm so sad I'm so
sad
people like yo hey man you can make your
life better if you want to make it
better no I can't because the hard part
about your story is that a lot of people
might come back to you and say you know
well you were never depressed then it's
a completely different thing exactly
that's why now I tell people like when
people ask have you ever been depressed
I'm like no I've I have felt depressed I
have felt depressed but I was not
depressed
yeah and ironically dude at the moment
out there like that happened and I was
like I prayed to God and I was like then
you don't want you don't depression or
you don't have anxiety is gone the
person who first told me that I know you
still have him it's never gonna go away
was a pastor oh really
yes crazy I was talking to him and he
was like yo man um I had some divine
moment with God and and he took away my
depression and then he looked at me and
he was like nah it's not gone it's never
gonna be gone and I looked at him and I
was like really yeah and so I kind of
got sad and depressed during that time I
got sad and depressed I was depressed I
was feeling like depressed you know
during that time and I start to beat
myself up and this was I want to say
today's May right do you know June July
June we're in June yeah so about five
months ago the
is when it happened and I met with him
and he was like nah you still have
depression and then for like two weeks I
started feeling depressed hmm and then I
beat myself up and then my buddy I'll
say his name because he's a dope dude
and I hope he doesn't mind but James
Tang he checked up on me and he's like
hey man what's going on I just felt like
I just yeah is everything okay and I was
like actually I'm feeling pretty bummed
because I thought I was not depressed
anymore
yeah then now I just spent two weeks in
depression I feel really bad about
myself and then he was like well you
gotta let yourself feel sad you can't
beat yourself up from feeling sad if you
fall back in the depression
you just got to realize okay well do I
want to stay in here and if I if you
can't then just stay in there for a
while I'll say okay accept it figure out
why you're feeling that way and I was
like I've never thought of it like that
yeah and so I sat there and I thought
about was like I'm feeling sad because
he said that and then I couldn't get
over my depression and so I just
struggled with not being able to get
over my depression which frustrated me
which created more depression yeah
perspective is is a huge thing it's hard
for a lot of people because sometimes
when people hurt and then you tell them
a story like this the the immediate
response is to be defensive because
they're in a very hurt place right
because they feel like they're in this
hole that they can't get out of and they
see somebody else who found that light
and then they want to categorize them as
oh you don't know what I'm going through
now because now you're not to be honest
I don't yeah I don't know what they're
going through and that's that's why if
you are going through depression you
kind of have to talk to someone about it
and it's not it's not your
responsibility because obviously you
have every right to be entitled to your
sadness and you can feel that when you
don't have to reach out but if you reach
out you will feel better you will not
feel this pain anymore yeah and you have
to listen to people when they talk to
you about that Stephan yeah like I just
want to shout out Yoshi because having a
younger brother who is depressed it's
hard man yeah it's hard because then
like he doesn't understand when I snap
he doesn't understand what these types
of things but without him in my life I
would not I would not be here yeah I
literally would not exist but even like
with that he's always taken care of me
know he's a really good brother yeah I
mean I feel like you guys because I just
heard a little bit of his story when I
had your brother on here
yes you say good things about me haha
never said about no but let me I think
like you guys I mean the immigrant story
is pretty hard you know like it's I
think it's something that a lot of
people don't understand like for example
like I only came here when I was like 2
3 years old so I didn't have the
spiritual a lot of youth what you did
now mind you my first language wasn't
English but you guys really couldn't
speaking you know and when you're
different and you stick out and then on
top of that having you know you guys are
very quirky human beings you
specifically it makes it even more
difficult to connect with people you
know you know that's why I gotta say
really quick and I don't mean - like you
could cut this out of you want I don't
care I want to say thank you so much
dude no like for being a friend of me
I'm serious it's like it's not easy it's
not easy for me in my opinion like
that's why I don't have a lot of friends
in the industry because it's hard to
connect with me because I am weird to
understand like I am a corgi dude you're
right
you're really right look at the group of
friends I had they're all [ __ ] weird
though yeah well like for me and how
I've always developed friendships it's
it's it was very different so I never
developed friendships first I mean
obviously you have to vibe and click on
certain things that's that's anybody
right that comes with romantic
relationships business relationships
personal relationships right yeah we had
that ground so after after that it's
just is this person a good person right